This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When you take the wrong turn off the highway or fumble a presentation at work, do you get mad at yourself for making a mistake? Do you silently kick yourself or maybe actually kick yourself? Self-criticism is often seen as heroic, maybe even noble. Many people think it's the shortest path to self-improvement. But is it? The belief that we need to be hard on ourselves, criticize ourselves, to succeed or reach our
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。当你从高速公路上转错弯，或者在工作中搞砸了一场演讲，你会因为自己犯了错而对自己生气吗？你会暗地里责备自己，甚至真的狠狠责备自己吗？自我批判通常被视为一种英雄般的气概，甚至可能是高尚的。许多人认为这是自我提升的最快捷径。但事实真的是这样吗？我们发现，在研究中阻碍自我同情的头号大敌，实际上正是那种认为我们必须对严厉要求自己、批判自己，才能成功、达到
goals or make a change is actually the number one block to self-compassion we found in the research. People are afraid that they're kind to themselves, they just won't get anything done. This week on Hidden Brain, the story of a psychologist who learned to stop beating up on herself and how you can convert your harsh inner critic into a friend. People who are more self-compassionate take more responsibility for their mistakes.
目标或做出改变的信念。人们担心，如果他们对自我温和，就什么事也做不成了。本周的《隐藏的大脑》，我们将讲述一位心理学家如何学会停止自我折磨，以及你该如何将严厉的内心中伤者转变为朋友。更有自我同情心的人会对自己的错误承担更多责任。
They're more conscientious and more likely to apologize. Ironically, even though the word self is in self-compassion, when you take that approach, it actually means you don't have to be so self-focused. Christian Neff's father left the family when she was a very small child. It was the late 1960s and he decided he was going to be a hippie. He picked up and moved to Hawaii. One of my first memories is going to visit him when I was about six years old in Maui. And him telling me, please don't call me dad, call me brother Dionysius because we are
他们更有责任心，也更有可能道歉。具有讽刺意味的是，尽管“自我”这个词包含在“自我同情”中，但当你采取这种方法时，实际上意味着你不必过度关注自我。克里斯蒂安·内夫（Christian Neff）很小的时候，她的父亲就离开了这个家。那是20世纪60年代末，他决定当一个嬉皮士。他收拾行囊搬到了夏威夷。我最早的记忆之一，大约六岁时去茂宜岛看望他。他告诉我，请不要叫我爸爸，叫我狄奥尼修斯兄弟（Brother Dionysius），因为我们
all God's children. I was incredibly uncomfortable and he said that to my brother as well. And so we couldn't call him brother Dionysius, that was just absurd. But we weren't, we didn't want us to call him dad. So, you know, for many, many years, both my brother and I were like, excuse me, could you pass the salt please, like without using any sort of name for him, because we didn't know what to call him. So that was kind of the backdrop of feeling unwanted and rejected. I should grow up.
都是上帝的孩子。我感到不可思议的局促不安，他对我的哥哥也是这么说的。所以我们不能叫他狄奥尼修斯兄弟，那简直太荒谬了。但我们又不想叫他爸爸。所以，你知道，很多很多年里，我和哥哥都觉得，打扰一下，请把盐递给我好吗——就好像不用任何称呼来叫他一样，因为我们不知道该叫他什么。这就是那种感到不被需要和被拒绝的背景。我应该长大了。
Kristen's insecurity about her dad shaped her romantic relationships. I was kind of felt insecure. And so there was always that sense of, if any boy liked me enough to want to be with me, I should go for it because there aren't a lot of options. And that actually played into my first marriage. Kristen married young. Her husband was a guy she met in college. He was a good guy, he was intelligent, he was handsome, and up until then my boyfriends
克里斯滕对父亲的不安全感影响了她的恋爱关系。我当时总觉得有些缺乏安全感。因此，那种感觉总是挥之不去：如果有哪个男孩足够喜欢我、想和我在一起，我就应该抓住机会，因为选择其实并不多。这实际上也影响了我的第一段婚姻。克里斯滕很早就结婚了。她的丈夫是她在大学里认识的一个人。他是个好人，聪明、英俊，在此之前，我的男朋友们
had all been kind of jerks. And so I kind of thought, okay, I've got a good one. I'll say yes when he asked me to marry him, that's amazing that someone would actually ask me to marry them. I'll just go for it. And I didn't have the larger understanding to realize that, well, what is it that I actually want in a man? It was like if it was somebody that was good enough.
其实都有点混蛋。所以我当时就想，好吧，我遇到了一个不错的人。当他向我求婚时，我答应了，有人竟然会向我求婚，这太不可思议了。我就这样接受了吧。当时我并没有更深刻的理解去意识到，好吧，我心目中真正想要的男人到底是什么样的？那感觉就像只要对方足够好就行了。
Kristen entered graduate school at the University of California Berkeley. She assumed her marriage was good. Her husband was committed to her. But there wasn't a lot of passion, but I didn't really know what I was missing until the man I worked for as a research assistant in graduate school, UC Berkeley, I found out I did have a lot of passion with and I started to realize, ah, of all, he was much older than me. He was about 15 years older than me. And so looking back, it probably played into some of my father issues, right? And so we just started developing
克里斯滕进入加州大学伯克利分校读研究生。她以为自己的婚姻很好。她的丈夫对她很忠诚。但并没有多少激情，直到我在加州大学伯克利分校的研究生院担任研究助理时，遇到了我的老板，我才真正知道了什么是激情。我开始意识到，哦，首先，他比我大得多。他比我大大约15岁。所以回想起来，这可能与我的恋父情结有关，对吧？于是我们开始发展
this intense attraction toward each other. At one point, I was working with him at his office and he was looking at me and I was looking at him at his office, and he was looking at me, and I was looking at him, and we started kissing. So we started having a physical relationship, and the passion and the intensity was like, and nothing I'd ever experienced before. Is it almost like it became a split personality?
出一种对彼此强烈的吸引力。有一次，我和他在办公室里工作，他看着我，我也看着他，在办公室里，他看着我，我也看着他，然后我们开始接吻。于是我们开始了一段亲密关系，那种激情和强烈程度，是我从未体验过的。这几乎就像是人格分裂吗？
So I was having this affair with Peter and I was hiding it from my husband and I was split in two. The half that was, the part of me that was still married was horrible. The part of me that was with Peter, I was like on cloud nine. I'd never felt such love, such passion. I felt so deeply seen. It was amazing. So it was like the best
所以我一边和彼得偷情，一边瞒着丈夫，整个人分裂成了两半。那一半仍然保持着婚姻状态的自我感觉糟糕透顶。而和彼得在一起的那部分自我，则让我感觉像上了九霄云外。我从未感受过如此的爱、如此的激情。我感到自己被深深地看见了。这太棒了。所以这就像是最好的一面
in the worst simultaneously and the two sides of me just didn't talk to each other. There was one more complicating factor. Kristen and Peter were also hiding their affair from his partner. So one more layer of something that I was horrified about that I just didn't deal with. To top it off, even as she was breaking all sorts of moral codes, Kristen was in graduate school to study moral development. There were so many ways in which it was wrong. Of course, I didn't even cross my mind at the time that I was as research assistant. He was really bad on his part, not to mention he was cheating, but he was, you know, I guess
和最坏的一面同时存在，而我心里的两个侧面互不理睬。还有一个复杂的因素。克里斯滕和彼得还要对他的伴侣隐瞒他们的地下情。这又多了一层让我感到恐惧、却又选择逃避的事情。最糟糕的是，就在她不断打破各种道德底线的同时，克里斯滕在研究生院研究的正巧是道德发展。有太多方面表明这是错误的。当然，当时我甚至没有想过我是他的研究助理。从他的角度来看，他这样做真的很糟糕，更不用说他在出轨了，但他，你知道的，我想
you consider that a sexually inappropriate relationship from his point of view. But at the time, that didn't even cross my mind. Kristen was preparing to spend a year in India for her dissertation research. Peter promised her he was going to leave his partner and join her. And we had made these plans. I thought this was it. I thought we were soulmates without a doubt. He was going to leave his partner for me.
从他的角度来看，你大概会认为那是一种性上不适当的关系。但在当时，我脑子里根本没想过这些。克里斯滕正准备去印度进行一年的博士论文研究。彼得向她保证，他会离开自己的伴侣并和她一起去。我们当时做好了这些计划。我以为就是这样了。我毫不怀疑地认为我们是灵魂伴侣。他会为了我离开他的伴侣。
He was going to come to India. We're going to spend our lives together. Kristen hadn't thought through how she tell her husband that their marriage was over. I assume that I would just tell him at some point, but I hadn't even gotten to that point when I was discovered this. She and Peter were at work one day when her husband paid a surprise visit. And he knocked on the door of the office, and it took a long time to answer that knock. Let's just say.
他会来印度。我们要一起共度余生。克里斯滕当时并没有考虑过该如何告诉丈夫他们的婚姻已经结束了。我以为我会在某个时候直接告诉他，但在我被发现之前，我甚至还没走到那一步。有一天她和彼得在工作时，她的丈夫突然来访。他在办公室门外敲了门，而且过了好一会儿才开门。我们只能这么说。
And when he opened the door, he knew and I knew and it's like, it all just came out. Oh God. Like one of the worst moments in my entire life. I told him how sorry it was for her, but I also said, you know, this is the love of my life. And I need to do this and we need to get a divorce. And obviously he was very, very angry about it. I mean, I just for divorce. She left for India and waited for Peter to join her. And I really thought he would come and he kept on saying he would come.
当他打开门时，他心知肚明，我也心知肚明，这就好像，一切都败露了。天哪。这简直是我一生中最糟糕的时刻之一。我告诉他我很抱歉，但我同时也说，你知道，这是我一生的挚爱。我必须这么做，我们必须离婚。显然他对此感到非常非常愤怒。我的意思是，我只是为了离婚。她动身去了印度，等待彼得来找她。我真的以为他会来，而且他一直说他会来。
Eventually, he broke the news to her. After I was there about three months, he actually said, Christian, I'm not going to come. At the say, I was a basket case would probably not be an understatement. It kind of, you know, played into that storyline again of, okay, here I am rejected yet again. I was very hurt and also felt betrayed. And you know, so I started to realize, well, did even meme what he said about wanting to spend the rest of his life with me. Maybe not. That was also hard.
最终，他向她摊牌了。我在那里呆了大约三个月后，他居然说：“克里斯滕，我不去了。”要说我当时彻底崩溃了，恐怕一点也不夸张。这某种程度上，你知道的，再次应验了那个剧本：好吧，我又一次被抛弃了。我非常受伤，同时也感到被背叛。所以，你知道的，我开始意识到，他之前说想跟我共度余生的话难道连一点真心都没有吗？也许真的没有。这也同样让人难以接受。
After a year overseas, Christian moved back to Berkeley to finish her PhD. She was still angry at Peter and had no interest in seeing him ever again. But then, Peter's partner, who knew about his affair with Kristen, contacted her. She sent me an email and said, Kristen, I need to tell you something. Peter is in the hospital with brain cancer. He only has a couple of months left to live. If you wanna see him, here's my visiting hours, you can come when I'm not there.
在海外呆了一年后，克里斯滕回到伯克利完成她的博士学位。她仍然生彼得的气，也毫无兴趣再见到他。但随后，知道彼得和克里斯滕有染的彼得伴侣联系了她。她给我发了一封电子邮件，说道：“克里斯滕，我有些事必须告诉你。彼得因脑癌住院了。他只剩下几个月的时间了。如果你想见他，这是我的探视时间，你可以在我不在的时候来。”
Holy s***, huh? Ha ha ha. First of all, I felt overwhelmingly grateful to her. Like what kind of woman would be so kind to this woman who tried to steal her partner that she would do this and let me know. Peter's partner had more news for Kristen. She said, Kristen, I have to tell you this isn't the first time this has happened with another woman. For whatever reason, she had decided to stick with them, but I guess this was the pattern that he would meet younger woman, say he
见鬼，是吗？哈哈。首先，我对她充满了感激之情。究竟是什么样的女人，会对这个试图抢走她伴侣的女人如此善良，以至于愿意这样做并把消息告诉她？彼得的伴侣还有更多消息要告诉克里斯滕。她说：“克里斯滕，我不得不告诉你，这并不是他第一次和其他女人发生这种事了。”无论出于什么原因，她决定留在他身边，但我想这是一个模式：他总是会遇到年轻女性，声称自己
was going to spend their life with him, and then dump them. Still, Kristen decided to visit Peter at the hospital. I just actually went once to see him because he was actually very close to the end and it was really difficult because he couldn't talk but he could see me. And he was making these weird sounds and faces because I don't know if he was in so much pain. He didn't seem happy to see me. And so I just said, my goodbyes. I think I told him that I forgave him because he was about to die and I didn't want him to end thinking that I hated him. It wasn't a Hollywood script version of how you say goodbye. It was a very awkward, uncertain, unclear version
会和她们共度一生，然后把她们甩了。尽管如此，克里斯滕还是决定去医院看望彼得。我其实只去看过他一次，因为他当时已经快不行了，这真的很艰难，因为他说不出话，但能看见我。他发出一些奇怪的声音和面部表情，因为我不知道他是不是痛苦不堪。他看起来并不高兴见到我。所以我只是向他道了别。我想我告诉过他我原谅了他，因为他快要死了，我不想让他在临终前还以为我恨他。这并不是好莱坞剧本里那种如何告别的版本，这是一个非常尴尬、充满不确定、不够清晰的
of how you say goodbye to someone. Peter died a few days later. And Christian was saddled with a toxic brew of emotions. I'm still incredibly angry at myself. I will admit there was a part of me that thought, well, is this somehow life saying, okay, you know, Kristen, if you do something like this and you you cheat and you have an affair, look what happens. I didn't really believe that, but that thought crossed my mind because I still felt so much shame and guilt about what I had done to my husband.
如何向某人告别的版本。彼得几天后就去世了。而克里斯滕则背负着一团有毒的情绪。我对自己仍然感到无比愤怒。我必须承认，我内心深处曾闪过这样一个念头：这难道是某种生活在发出警告：好吧，你知道的，克里斯滕，如果你做这种事，如果你作弊出轨，看会有什么下场。我其实并不相信这种说法，但这个念头确实在我的脑海中闪过，因为我对自已对丈夫所做的事仍然感到无比的羞耻和内疚。
I asked Kristen about the conversations she had with herself in the days that followed her visit with Peter. You're feeling horrible for lying. It's not who you are. You've broken your vows. You've hurt someone. And then add on that coming back and all the layers of being angry at him because he basically, I don't know if he used me or not, but he basically was honest with me, dumped
我问克里斯滕，在去探望彼得后的那几天里，她内心都在对自己说些什么。你因为撒谎而感觉糟透了。这不是真正的你。你违背了誓言。你伤害了别人。然后再加上回到这里，所有的情绪层层叠加，对充满愤怒，因为他基本上，我不知道他是不是利用了我，但他基本上就是对我说了实话，然后把我甩了
me, left me in India. And then he's got brain cancer and we wanted to forgive him, I'm laughing, but of course it wasn't funny at the time. It was like a bad soap opera. Of all people, Christen told herself, she ought to have known better. She was doing a PhD on moral development for crying out loud. Honesty has always been one of my core values. I am by nature an incredibly honest person. Line comes very unnaturally to me.
把我抛弃在印度。然后他得了脑癌，而我们还想要原谅他，我在笑，但当时当然一点也不好笑。这就像一幕糟糕的肥皂剧。克里斯滕对自己说，放眼所有人，她本来应该更懂事的。她可是顶着“为了老天爷”的名义在攻读道德发展的博士学位。诚实一直是我的核心价值观之一。我天生就是一个极其诚实的人。撒谎对我来说非常不自然。
So not only was I studying world development, not only was morality kind of part of myself concept and honesty part of myself concept, so that when I had done this, not only was I hypocritical, but I was completely inauthentic. So I just felt a lot of shame, a lot of shame. But this had happened that I had allowed it to happen. You know, there's even the slight thought, did I somehow cause this to happen through my karma? You know, I don't really believe in karma, but brother Dionysius, certainly my dad, certainly talked a lot my karma. I don't really believe in karma, but brother Dianisha, certainly
所以，我不仅在研究道德发展，不仅道德和诚实构成了我自我概念的一部分——以至于当我做出这种事时，我不仅虚伪，而且完全失去了自我。所以我感到极其羞耻，无比羞耻。但事情已经发生了，而且是我纵容它发生的。你知道，甚至还有一种隐隐的闪念：难道这一切是通过某种因果报应（业力）由我引起的吗？你知道，我其实并不相信因果报应，但狄奥尼修斯兄弟，我的父亲，确实常常谈论因果报应。我其实并不相信因果报应，但狄奥尼修斯兄弟，确实
my dad, certainly talked a lot about karma. What I was was I was really cold to myself. Well, maybe you deserve this. You know, you did this. This is what happens. I don't feel sorry for you. You know, it was just an intense coldness toward myself. Coldness mixed with shame. Perhaps you are familiar with an inner voice that says things like this. That castigates you, criticizes you, belittles you. A voice that tells you that you are no good, that you deserve to suffer. In the aftermath of her meltdown, Christian became more and more aware of that voice inside her.
我的父亲，确实常常谈论因果报应。我对自己的态度非常冷酷。好吧，也许你罪有应得。你知道，这是你干的。这就是自作自受。我才不同情你呢。你知道，那是一种对自己极其冷酷的态度。冷酷与羞耻交织在一起。或许你对这样一种内心的声音并不陌生：它会对你评头论足、严厉批判、贬低嘲讽。一个告诉你你一无是处、罪有应得去受苦的声音。在经历了一系列精神崩溃之后，克里斯滕对内心那种声音的觉察越来越深。
She would never dream of saying harsh and cruel things to other people. So why was she doing it to herself? The vast majority of people say they're significantly more compassionate and understanding and kinder to other people than they are to themselves. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. When she was a graduate student at UC Berkeley, Kristen Neff made a series of choices in her personal life.
她做梦也不会对别人说出如此刻薄残酷的话。那么，她为什么偏偏要这样折磨自己呢？绝大多数人都会承认，他们对待他人明显比对待自己要更富有同情心、更能理解包容、也更善良。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。在加州大学伯克利分校读研究生时，克里斯滕·内夫在个人生活中做出了一系列选择。
She would come to regret them for a long time. These mistakes filled her with shame, and judgment, and self-criticism. After she became a psychologist, she started to study the harsh ways people talk to themselves. Christian, I routinely find myself saying very critical things to myself that I would never dream of saying to another human being, you've studied all the ways people beat up on themselves. What do you find? In my research, actually, the vast majority of people say they're significantly more
这些选择让她在很长一段时间里后悔莫及。这些错误让她充满了羞耻、评判和自我批判。在她成为一名心理学家后，她开始研究人们对自己进行严厉言语攻击的方式。克里斯滕，我经常发现自己会对自已说一些极其刻薄的话，而这些话我做梦都不会对另一个人说。你研究过人们折磨自己的各种方式，你发现了什么？在我的研究中，实际上，绝大多数人都表示，他们对他人明显要
compassionate and understanding and kinder to other people than they are to themselves, especially when they make a mistake or fail some way. It's interesting. Some people manifest this with like harsh language, with name calling, but you know, they swear at themselves, they really use a harsh tone. Other people like myself, it's more just a sense
更富同情心、更能理解、更善良，尤其是当别人犯错或以某种方式失败时。这很有趣。有些人表现为刻薄的言辞、辱骂，你知道的，他们会咒骂自己，使用非常严厉的语气。而另一些人，像我一样，则更多是一种
of coldness or shame. Other people almost like they disassociate, almost like by abandoning themselves. Just the way you might with someone you didn't like, you just stopped returning their calls, right? And so that can manifest is just a shutting down, a going numb. Sometimes it's just a feeling of disappointment,
冷漠或羞耻感。还有人几乎表现为解离，就像抛弃自我一样。就像你对待一个你讨厌的人那样，你只是不再回他们的电话，对吧？因此，这可以表现为一种自我关闭、变得麻木。有时只是一种失望的情绪，
like, you know, like I said, a sigh out. That's the way it manifests. But pretty much everyone has a self-critic that comes out one way or another. You've talked about the concept of the inner critic. I think all of us have experienced this. What is the role that the inner critic plays in our lives? Well, so the inner critic actually plays an important role.
就像，你知道的，正如我所说，叹了一口气。这就是它表现出来的方式。但几乎每个人都有一个时不时跳出来的内在批判者。你曾谈到过“内心的批判者”这个概念。我想我们所有人都经历过这一点。内心的批判者在我们的生活中扮演着什么角色？那么，内心的批判者实际上扮演着一个重要的角色。
And I like to say we should have beat ourselves up for beating ourselves up because the inner critic comes from the simple desire to stay safe. Right. So what we know about the inner critic is it actually is tapping into the body's fight flight or freeze response. And so we're scared of something and gosh, when we make a mistake or fail, it's scary. We feel frightened. We feel threatened. So we either fight ourselves, thinking we could control the situation and be safe. Are we flee and shame from the perceived judgments of others?
我喜欢说：我们应该为自己“痛打落水狗”的行为而痛打自己一番，因为内心的批判者源于一种渴望保持安全的简单愿望。没错。所以我们对内心批判者的了解是，它实际上是在利用身体的战斗、逃跑或冻结反应。我们害怕某些事情，天哪，当我们犯错或失败时，这是可怕的。我们感到恐惧。我们感到受到威胁。所以我们要么与自己对抗，以为这样就能控制局面并保持安全。要么在别人的察觉到的评判中逃跑和羞耻。
Are we kind of freezing, get stuck in rumination? And these are all really natural ways we try to stay safe. So you might even say the motivation of inner critic is a good one, even though the consequences are anything but. Our inner self-critic may have forced evolved to teach us how to survive. If you make a mistake when dealing with a predator, a mistake that costs you a limb, for example, it might make sense to beat yourself up over your mistake, so you never repeat it. But today, this harsh teacher shows up even when we commit trivial infractions.
或者陷入僵局，陷入反刍思维？这些都是我们试图保持安全的非常自然的方式。所以你甚至可以说，内在批判者的动机是好的，尽管其后果绝非如此。我们内心的自我批判者可能是为了教导我们如何生存而进化来的。如果你在对付捕食者时犯了错误，比如一个让你失去肢体的错误，那么因为这个错误而狠狠责备自己或许是有道理的，这样你就永远不会重蹈覆辙。但如今，这位严厉的老师甚至在我们犯下微不足道的违规行为时也会跳出来。
And we actually feel incredibly threatened even when we do something as simple as a friend and you see that she's, we don't know she's put on a little weight, you know that she's got a little bump and you say, oh, when are you expecting? And she says, I'm not expecting. And by the way, that happened to me not too long ago. I was really bloated. And someone said to me, when are you expecting? And I said, I'm not expecting.
而即使在我们做了一些微不足道的事情时，我们实际上也会感到无比强烈的威胁，比如你看到一个朋友，你发现她，我们不知道她长胖了一点点，你知道她有了一点小肚子，然后你说：“哦，预产期是什么时候呀？”她说：“我没有怀孕。”顺便说一句，不久前这事就在我身上发生过。我当时真的很腹胀。然后有人对我说：“你什么时候生呀？”我说：“我没有怀孕。”
And so something like that happens. And it feels as serious as a predator chasing you about to kill you. Because what's happened is your self-concept at that moment is obliterated. And it feels like a death because our ego is hurt, and we confuse our ego with our actual bodily cells, at least mentally. And when we fail, or we make a mistake, or someone criticizes us, or doesn't accept
所以当类似的事情发生时。它感觉就像一只捕食者在追赶你、即将置你于死地一样严重。因为发生的情况是，你在那一刻的自我概念被彻底抹去了。这感觉就像是一场死亡，因为我们的自我（小 ego）受到了伤害，我们在精神上至少把自我与我们实际的身体细胞混淆了。当我们失败、犯错，或者有人批评我们、不接受我们、
us, or reject us, it does feel like a death. And I hate to say this, but some people do go so as far as to try to take their own life that they feel too much shame. Shame is a big factor in alcoholism, in addiction, in suicidal ideation, and eating disorders, a huge number of dysfunctional behaviors are driven by shame. Shame is kind of the undercurrent behind everything. So the difference between shame and guilt, for instance, guilt is I did something bad. It's about our behaviors.
或者拒绝我们时，这确实感觉像是一场死亡。我很不想这么说，但有些人甚至会因为感到过多的羞耻而试图结束自己的生命。羞耻感是酗酒、成瘾、自杀意念和进食障碍中的一个巨大因素，大量的功能失调行为都是由羞耻感驱动的。羞耻感可以说是潜藏在一切背后的暗流。比如，羞耻感和罪恶感之间的区别在于，罪恶感是“我做了一件坏事”。它关乎我们的行为。
Shame is I am bad. Is the connection between perfectionism and our inner critic? Is that also connected, do you think, to the phenomenon of shame? Oh, yeah, absolutely. I mean, some perfectionism is like, I want to do my very best, but if I don't, I'm still okay. That's actually useful perfectionism. A maladaptive perfectionism, unhelpful perfectionism, is if I'm not perfect, I am bad. and that feeling of I am bad is shame. Feeling shame, feeling the pain caused by the inner self-critic prompts many of us to do things that are unhelpful to our mental well-being. One of those responses, we try to suppress the pain by artificially propping up our self-esteem. Self-esteem, there's nothing wrong with self-esteem.
而羞耻感则是“我是个坏人”。完美主义和我们内心的批判者之间有什么联系吗？你认为这也与羞耻现象有关吗？哦，是的，绝对有。我的意思是，有些完美主义是这样的：我想做到最好，但如果我没做到，我也还是可以接受的。这实际上是有用的完美主义。而一种适应不良的完美主义、无益的完美主义则是：如果我不是完美的，我就是个坏人。而“我是个坏人”这种感觉就是羞耻。体验到羞耻，感受到内在自我批判者带来的痛苦，促使我们许多人做出不利于心理健康的事情。其中一种反应是：我们试图通过人为地支撑自尊来压制痛苦。自尊，自尊本身并没有错。
Self-esteem is just a judgment or evaluation of self-worth. And when you care about yourself, you're gonna have a higher sense of self-esteem. The problem is a lot of people get their self-esteem from, again, identifying with their ego, right? So I have high self-esteem if I think I'm attractive, or if other people like me, or if I succeed in business or sports or whatever it is, it's important to me to
自尊只是一种对自我价值的判断或评估。当你关爱自己时，你就会有更高的自尊感。问题在于，许多人的自尊再次来源于将自己与小我（ego）等同起来，对吧？所以我拥有高自尊的前提是：我认为自己很有吸引力，或者其他人喜欢我，或者我在商业、体育或任何对我很重要的领域取得了成功。
succeed at. And so in an eye way, when we're basing our self-esteem on our ego, this judgment of self-worth, then anytime we fail or make a mistake or get rejected, then because we're identified with our ego, again, it feels like a death when this happens. It feels very, very serious. And of course, the times that you actually might need a boost is actually when things are down for you, and that might be precisely when self-esteem deserts you. Exactly. So I'll just give you an example, a funny, sadly true story. I was with a group of friends. We were visiting some writing stables.
所以在某种程度上，当我们把自尊建立在小我之上，建立在这种对自我价值的判断上时，那么每当我们失败、犯错或被拒绝时，由于我们再次将自己与小我等同起来，这就感觉像是一场死亡。这感觉非常非常严重。当然，你最需要精神提振的时候，恰恰是你处于人生低谷的时候，而这可能正是自尊抛弃你的时候。完全正确。所以我就举个例子，一个搞笑但悲哀的真实故事。我当时和一群朋友在一起。我们去参观一些马厩。
And there was this old Spanish writing instructor. And I was younger. I'm part Greek, so I kind of Mediterranean looks. And he looked at me and he said, oh, you are very beautiful. I was like, well, gosh, you know, my self-esteem boost, you are very beautiful. I was like, oh gosh, you know, my self-esteem boost feeling good about myself. And he said, don't ever shave your moustache.
那里有一位老态龙钟的西班牙马术教练。而那时我还年轻。我有一半希腊血统，所以长相有点地中海风格。他看着我，然后说：“哦，你长得非常漂亮。”我当时就想，哇，天哪，你知道的，我的自尊心得到了提振，你长得非常漂亮。我当时想，哦天哪，你知道的，我的自尊心得到了提振，感觉自己棒极了。然后他说：
Ha! Like, okay, you know, self-esteem here one moment, gone the next, right? And so it's very fragile. So it's really humiliating when someone tells you not to shave your moustache. And so it's a fair weather friend because it's based on externals. Or even when it's based on internals, because we aren't perfect, we're always going to get
“千万别刮你的小胡子。”哈！就像是，好吧，你知道的，自尊心这东西，刚才还在，一转眼就没了，对吧？所以它是极其脆弱的。因此，当有人叫你别刮胡子时，那是相当羞辱人的。所以它是个“患难见不到真情”的朋友，因为它建立在外在基础之上。甚至当它建立在内在基础之上时，由于我们并不完美，我们总会
it wrong sometimes. Right, because you might think of yourself as being a very conscientious person or a very persistent person, and then you might not succeed or persist at a certain task, and then what happens to that inner self concept that you have? Exactly. Exactly. That's the problem with self-esteem. There's nothing wrong with having it, but it's how do you get it?
在某些时候把事情搞砸。没错，因为你可能会认为自己是一个非常认真负责的人，或者是一个非常有毅力的人，然后你可能在某个任务上没有成功或坚持下去，那么你内心的那种自我概念会发生什么变化呢？完全正确。完全正确。这就是自尊的问题所在。拥有它并没有错，但问题在于你是如何获得它的？
Do you get it from being better than other people, from being a narcissist, and really ego-defensive, or do you get it from having to be perfect or having to succeed, and all of these things are bound to eventually lead to problems. The harsh inner critic doesn't have consequences just for us. When we are harsh with ourselves, that harsh voice can also come out in our conversations with others. Part of the problem is that many of us go to pains to hide our inner critic from the outside world. Even as our inside voice gets harsher, we try to project confidence and success to the outside world.
你是通过表现得比别人优越、通过成为一个自恋者并进行强烈的自我防御来获得它，还是通过必须完美或必须成功来获得它？所有这些最终都注定会引发问题。严厉的内省批判者带来的后果不仅作用于我们自身。当我们对自己严厉时，那种严厉的声音也会在与他人的对话中流露出来。部分问题在于，我们许多人都费尽心机向外界隐藏我们的内心批判者。即便我们内心的声音变得越来越严厉，我们仍然试图向外界投射出自信和成功。
Eventually, the gap can become overwhelming. If you don't give yourself compassion and kindness and support when you're experiencing these negative emotions, and instead of the way you try to deal with them, it's by like shoving them down, suppressing them, bodilying them up, then what's going to happen is you haven't actually dealt with those negative emotions. You haven't processed them. And what we know very clearly from the psychological research is whatever you resist actually grows stronger.
最终，这种巨大的落差可能会让人不堪重负。如果你在经历这些负面情绪时，没有给予自己同情、善良和支持，而是试图通过压抑它们、把它们强行塞回肚子里来应对，那么接下来会发生的是，你实际上并没有真正处理好这些负面情绪。你没有消化它们。心理学研究非常清楚地告诉我们：你所抗拒的，实际上会变得更加强大。
So trying to avoid them creates this pressure so that eventually you've actually strengthened the negative emotion so that when it comes out it's even worse than it would have been otherwise. I feel like one of the things that happens for many people, you come home after a stressful day, you're exhausted, you've had a difficult time, maybe the day has not gone well,
因此，试图回避它们会产生一种压力，最终你会实际上强化了负面情绪，以至于当它再次爆发时，会比原本更糟糕。我觉得许多人身上会发生这样一件事：你带着疲惫不堪、经历了一番艰难折磨的心情结束了充满压力的一天回到家，也许这一天过得并不顺心，
maybe you're beating up on yourself for things that you have done or things that you should have done that you didn't do. And one of the things that we do because we're not processing this in a way that's healthy is that we take out this anger or our impatience or frustrations on other people. If we're criticizing ourselves and beating ourselves up, it means we're agitated. Our cortisol levels are elevated. And so that activation means we're more likely to have a shorter fuse with others. And then also other people can pick up on our internal mindset. So if you're feeling kind of grumpy and agitated, other people not only are they grumpy and agitated
也许你正在为自己做过的事或本该做却没有做的事而自我鞭笞。而我们所做的一件事情，由于我们没有以健康的方式处理这种情绪，就是把这种愤怒、不耐烦或沮丧情绪发泄在别人身上。如果我们一直在批评自己、鞭笞自己，那就意味着我们处于焦虑状态。我们的皮质醇水平升高了。这种激活状态意味着我们对他人失去耐心的可能性更高。此外，其他人也能感知到我们内在的心态。因此，如果你感到有些暴躁和焦虑，其他人不仅会因为
because you're being grumpy and agitated, but they can also feel your vibe, so to speak, which makes them grumpy and agitated. So at least to this really downward spiral. And then it doesn't lead to good outcomes typically. I want to talk about one related idea, the role that are in our inner critic plays in shaping our relationships with other people.
你的暴躁和焦虑而感到暴躁和焦虑，他们还能感受到你的“磁场”（vibe），可以说是这种状态让他们也变得暴躁和焦虑。这最终导致了一个真正向下的螺旋。而且通常不会带来好的结果。我想谈谈一个相关的想法：我们内心的批判者在塑造我们与他人关系方面所起的作用。
In the movie Bridesmaids, the main character Annie is a single woman who feels her life is a mess. She complains about it to her friend Megan, and I want to play you a short clip from the movie. I got fired from my job, I got kicked out of my apartment, I can't pay any of my bills. My car is a piece of s***, I don't have any friends. The last time I find interesting about that Annie. It's interesting to me that you have absolutely no friends.
在电影《伴娘》（Bridesmaids）中，主角安妮是一个单身女性，她觉得自己的人生一团糟。她向朋友梅根抱怨，我想放一小段电影原声给你们听。我被公司炒了鱿鱼，被房租赶了出来，连账单都付不起。我的破车烂得像坨屎，连个朋友都没有。我觉得安妮最有趣的地方在于。我觉得很有趣的是，你居然觉得自己完全没有朋友。
You know why it's interesting? Here's a friend standing directly in front of you, trying to talk to you and you choose to talk about the fact that you don't have any friends. You know what I mean? No, I don't think you want any help. I think you want to have a pity party. Yeah, I think anyone's a little pity party.
你知道为什么有趣吗？这里就站着一个朋友，就站在你面前，努力想跟你说话，而你却偏偏选择去谈论你没有朋友这件事。你知道我的意思吗？不，我觉得你根本不需要什么帮助。我觉得你只是想开个“同情派对”（自怜派对）。对，我觉得任何人都会开点小自怜派对。
So I think what was happening in that clip is when you just focus on self-criticism and everything's wrong and we're really in this negativity bias, you can't even see the good things like you actually have friends, right? So things aren't as bad as you think they are. You know, we criticize yourself.
所以我想那个片段里发生的事情是，当你只专注于自我批判，觉得一切都出了问题，并且真正陷入这种负面偏差时，你甚至连好的一面都看不到了，比如你其实是有朋友的，对吧？所以事情并没有你想象的那么糟。你知道，我们在批判自己。
I'm so hopeless. I'm so worthless. And it kind of starts morphing into self pity. There may be part of us that's hoping that I will get a compassionate response from others. But of course, it doesn't because who wants to be around someone who's full of self pity. One of the things that I took away from your work that was really interesting is that self-criticism can sometimes be an outgrowth of self-focus or self-absorption. That in some ways the person who is regularly criticizing themselves really is often
我太没用了。我真是一文不值。这开始逐渐演变成自怜。我们内心深处可能有一部分希望从别人那里得到同情的反应。但当然，这不会发生，因为谁愿意和一个充满自怜的人呆在一起呢？从你的研究中，我收获的一个非常有趣的点是：自我批判有时可能是过度关注自我或自我沉溺的一种结果。在某些方面，那个经常批评自己的人，实际上往往
unable to step outside themselves. You write so shame and self-criticism, they're incredibly self-absorbed states. You're just thinking about how awful you are, how horrible you are, what a big mistake you made. So self-deprecation of the people may kind of like it a little bit. Self-criticism is, when it's especially when it's done without humor, but it's really serious, just can turn people off and do rally, really. So besides being very critical of ourselves,
无法跳出自我。你写道：羞耻和自我批判，它们是极其自我沉溺的状态。你满脑子想的都是自己有多糟糕、有多可怕、自己犯了多大的错误。因此，人们可能会有点喜欢贬低自己。自我批判，尤其是当它缺乏幽默感、变得非常严肃时，真的会把人推开，让人大倒胃口。所以，除了对我们自己极度苛刻之外，
can you talk about how some of us denigrate others to feel better about ourselves? So it's superficially designed to boost our self-esteem, but I can't imagine that this can be good for relationships. Right, so, well, you know, Shankar, can I ask you a question? Yes. If I said your podcast was average, how would you feel? I would feel deeply wounded.
你能谈谈我们当中有些人是如何通过贬低他人来让自己感觉更好的吗？所以它表面上是为了提升我们的自尊，但我无法想象这对人际关系会有什么好处。对，那么，你知道，香卡，我可以问你一个问题吗？可以。如果我说你的播客很平庸，你会有什么感觉？我会感到深深的受伤。
You feel deeply wounded, right? And if you said my book was average, I'd feel deeply wounded, right? So we all suffer from this, don't we? We all have to feel special and above average, just for baseline to feel good about ourselves. And so the social comparison is really built into the need for self-esteem. line to feel good about ourselves. And so this social comparison is really built in to the need for self-esteem. And so what we start doing, because we all want to be above average,
你感到深深的受伤，对吧？如果你说我的书很平庸，我也会感到深深的受伤，对吧？所以我们都深受其害，不是吗？我们都必须觉得自己很特别、高于平均水平，才能在基准线上对自我感觉良好。因此，社会比较确实根植于对自尊的需求之中。对自我感觉良好。因此，这种社会比较深深植根于对自尊的需求之中。所以我们开始做的是，因为我们都想高于平均水平，
is one way to feel above average is to say, oh, that other scholars work isn't quite as good as mine, or that other person's podcast isn't quite as good as mine. We do it subtly, maybe not even intentionally, That isn't quite as good as mine. We do it subtly, maybe not even intentionally, but we're always trying, if we can get away with it, to subtly put others down and puff ourselves up in comparison so that we can again boost our self-esteem. But in some ways, I think what I hear you saying is that this is like a sugar high. It's sort of a transient burst that you get. But in some ways, it's keeping us from sort of exercising the kind of compassion that can actually draw us closer to other people
那么感觉高于平均水平的一种方法就是说：“哦，那个学者的研究不如我的好，”或者“那个人的播客不如我的好。”我们做得非常微妙，甚至可能并非有意为之，那其实不如我的好。我们做得非常微妙，甚至可能并非有意为之，但如果我们能侥幸逃过，我们总是试图去微妙地贬低他人，并在比较中抬高自己，从而再次提升我们的自尊。但在某些方面，我想我听到你的意思是，这就像是一场糖分高潮（sugar high）。你获得的是一种短暂的爆发。但在某种程度上，这让我们无法去行使那种真正能将我们拉近他人、
or closer to ourselves. Yeah, so when we have to feel better than others, to feel good about ourselves, that creates distance in relationships, right? But if we can be compassionate toward ourselves and others, we accept that we're flawed. It also allows us to be closer to others because we accept that they're flawed. We accept that we're flawed. We can actually feel connected to others and our imperfection as opposed to thinking
或拉近自我的同情心。是的，所以当我们必须感觉比别人优越才能自我感觉良好时，这就在人际关系中造成了距离，对吧？但如果我们能对自己和他人抱有同情心，我们就会接受自己是有缺陷的。这也让我们能够更亲近他人，因为我们接受了他们也是有缺陷的。我们接受了我们是有缺陷的。我们实际上可以与他人的不完美建立连接，而不是认为
that they're flawed, but I'm not. So that's one of the reasons self-compassion is so good for relationships that when we can be more forgiving toward ourselves, we can be more forgiving toward others. We don't have to be better than others in order to feel good about ourselves, which means we can have more intimacy in relationships.
他们有缺陷而我没有。这就是为什么自我同情对人际关系如此之好的原因之一：当我们能够对自我更加宽容时，我们就能对他人更加宽容。我们不必为了自我感觉良好而表现得比别人更好，这意味着我们在人际关系中可以拥有更多亲密感。
When we come back, how to take the voice of our inner critic and turn down the volume? You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Kristen Neff is a psychologist at the University of Texas at Austin. She finds that we're often harder on ourselves than we are on anyone else. We criticize ourselves for shortcomings, beat up on ourselves for trivial mistakes. Christian, while you were in graduate school and you went through this terrible saga, you found all kinds of ways to beat up on yourself, but you also
广告回来后，我们将探讨如何收容我们内心批判者的声音并将其调低音量。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。克里斯滕·内夫是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的心理学家。她发现，我们对自己的苛刻程度往往超过对任何其他人的苛刻程度。我们为自己的缺点而批判自己，为微不足道的错误而自我鞭笞。克里斯滕，当你在读研究生并经历了那场可怕的波折时，你发现了各种折磨自己的方式，但你也
started a journey toward self-compassion. Can you tell me what happened in your own life that led you in that direction? Yes, so I was a basket case, like I said, but I was also nervous about getting my PhD when I get a job. And I had learned that mindfulness meditation was good for stress. I had heard this and I was in Berkeley, you know, and there was a meditation group just on the street from where I lived. I was a Buddhist group and
开启了一段通往自我同情的旅程。你能告诉我，你生活中的什么经历引导你走向了那个方向吗？是的，正如我所说，我当时完全崩溃了，但我也对拿到博士学位后能否找到工作感到焦虑。我曾听说正念冥想对缓解压力有好处。我听说过这个，而且我当时在伯克利，你知道的，我住的地方街区就有一个冥想小组。那是一个佛教小组，
the very first night I went, the woman leading the group, talked about self-compassion. You know, and I had heard of compassion. I knew that Buddhist talked about compassion, but I'd never heard of self-compassion before. And it was a real light bulb moment for me. It was like, wait a second. You're allowed to be kind and supportive to yourself. I'm even if you've done something wrong, which of course, so this is when I was going through everything with Peter and all the shame and all the guilt and all the drama of it. When I tried to turn the lens
就在我去的那个第一天晚上，带头的那位女士谈到了自我同情。你知道的，我听说过同情。我知道佛教徒会谈论同情，但我以前从未听说过“自我同情”。这对我来说是一个真正的“灵光一现”时刻。那感觉就像，等一下。原来你被允许对自我保持善良和支持，即使你做错了事，当然，这就是我当时正在经历与彼得之间的一切、所有的羞耻、所有的罪恶感以及其中所有的戏剧性冲突时的感受。当我试着把同情的镜头
of compassion inward and I tried it out. So, you know, Kristen, yes, I know you feel really horrible about leaving your husband and cheating on him and all that. But everyone makes mistakes. You did your best at the time. You wanted this new experience of love that you never had before and that's so human. So I started being warmer and more supportive and more understanding toward myself. And the crazy thing is it didn't make me say, okay, well that's fine. I'll just cheat on whoever. It's not like it, although it caused me to dismiss my behavior. And actually, though, I mean to take more responsibility
转向内向，并且尝试这样做时。所以，你知道的，克里斯滕，是的，我知道你因为离开丈夫并对我不忠而感到非常糟糕，每个人都会犯错。你在当时已经尽力了。你渴望这种从未体验过的新爱情，这是人之常情。所以我开始对自我更加温暖、更具支持性、更加理解。而疯狂的是，这并没有让我说：“好吧，那没关系。我去对任何人不忠都可以。”这并不意味着我是在为自己的行为开脱。事实上，它反而让我承担了更多
for it, I could turn toward it because what was happening is I couldn't even look at it. It was still so painful and I was feeling all the shame, but I couldn't even really hold a process what I'd done. And so the more I was able to say, yes, you're feeling pain, it was human, you made a mistake. I still felt guilty in the sense that yes, I regretted my behavior. I wish I would have had the wherewithal or the maturity to not have been in that situation, but that's where I was. And so the kinder, more supportive I could be toward myself,
责任，我可以直面它了，因为之前发生的情况是，我甚至无法直视它。它依然是如此痛苦，我感受到了所有的羞耻，但我甚至无法真正去承载或消化我所做过的事。因此，当我能够更多地对自己说：是的，你在经历痛苦，这是人之常情，你犯了错。我依然感到内疚，因为是的，我为自己的行为感到后悔。我希望自己当时能有足够的智慧或成熟度来避免陷入那种境地，但事实就是如此。所以，我对自己能够越发善良、更有支持性，
the more able I was to take responsibility for what I had done, but also to move on from it, right? So instead of being stuck there, I was able to learn my lessons, okay? I'm never gonna get myself in that situation again if I can help it, and to really commit much more firmly to honesty and trying to be forced for good in the world and not to harm others.
我就越有能力为自己所做过的事承担责任，同时也能够从中走出来，对吧？所以，我没有被困在原地，而是能够吸取教训，好吧？如果我能控制的话，我绝不会再让自己陷入那种境地，并且更坚定地致力于诚实，努力成为世界上的一股向善力量，不去伤害他人。
You know, it's interesting as you're saying this because I'm realizing that when you were really hard on yourself, part of what was happening, I think, was you were telling yourself, look, I'm such a good person that I can beat up on myself for doing this really bad thing. But when you're self compassionate, it's almost like you're saying, I'm actually acknowledging what actually happened. Absolutely. So the self critic, the back of the self critic is tall. I am such a good person that I know what a bad person I am. And also, the self-critic has a sense of control as if I should have been able to get it
你知道，当你这么说时很有意思，因为我意识到，当你对自己非常严厉时，其中一部分原因，我认为，是在对自己说：看啊，我是一个如此善良的人，以至于我可以为自己做了这件极其糟糕的事而痛打自己。但当你对自己充满同情时，那感觉就像是在说：我实际上在承认真实发生的事情。完全正确。所以，自我批判者的逻辑底色是：我是一个如此善良的人，以至于我清楚地知道自己是一个多么糟糕的人。而且，自我批判者还带有一种对控制感的需求，就好像我本来应该能够做到
right, even though I didn't. And that sense of control, and kind of like I am a good person that I know what a bad person I am, that kind of, again, props up the ego. And so what you do with self-compassion is not like you're saying, I'm a bad, worthless person, but what you're saying is I'm a human being. Yes, I wasn't in control. There was a lot of immaturity, a lot of factors that played in to the decisions I made. I'm not the only one who's hurt someone or that did something they really regretted.
对，即使我当时没有。而那种掌控感，以及那种觉得自己是个好人、我知道自己是个坏人的感觉，再次支撑起了我的自尊。所以你在进行自我关怀时，并不是在说“我是一个糟糕的、毫无价值的人”，而是在说“我是一个人”。是的，我当时无法控制。有许多不成熟的因素，以及许多影响我做出决定的因素。我不是唯一一个伤害过别人或做过让自己深感后悔的事情的人。
And then when you open to that, when you open to the fact that you're a flawed human being, I like to say what you're doing is you're becoming a compassionate mess. You're still a mess. You don't expect yourself to be perfect, but when you're compassionate toward that mess, it becomes much more workable.
而当你敞开心扉接受这一点时，当你坦然接受自己是一个有缺点的人时，我喜欢把这称为：你正在变成一个充满同理心的乱麻。你依然是一团糟。你并不期望自己是完美的，但当你以同理心对待这种混乱时，它就会变得更容易处理。
You're more able to see what you've done to own it, to take responsibility for it. You have more emotional resources to learn from your mistakes and commit to trying to do something differently in the future. I'm wondering as you were doing this though, was there a part of you, the self-critical part of you that was, I would say, in response, you know what, Christian, you're just letting yourself off the hook? Oh, yeah, absolutely, right. So in response, you know what, Christian, you're just letting yourself off the hook. Oh, yeah, absolutely, right. So when you first learn self-compassion, it's almost like there's one voice that says,
你更能看清自己做了什么并勇敢承认，为之承担责任。你有更多的情感资源从错误中吸取教训，并承诺在未来尝试做一些改变。不过，当你在做这件事时，我很好奇，你的内心深处有没有一个部分——那个自我批判的部分——它会这样回应：你知道吗，克里斯汀，你只是在放纵自己？哦，是的，绝对有，没错。所以作为回应，“你知道吗，克里斯汀，你只是在放纵自己。”哦，是的，绝对有，没错。所以当你刚开始学习自我关怀时，几乎就像是有两个声音：
okay, I'm going to try to understand and support myself. I'm only human. And another voice that says, you're full of it, you're just letting yourself off the hook, because we aren't used to being kind and supportive toward ourselves. What happens is the self-critic resist reality. The self-critic somehow believes that perfection is possible if we just try hard enough. The self-compassion is like, hey, reality actually means making mistakes. Well, that's okay.
一个声音说：“好吧，我要试着理解并支持自己。我只是个人。”另一个声音则说：“少来这套，你只是在给自己开脱。”因为我们不习惯对自己的善良和支持。结果就是，自我批判者会抗拒现实。自我批判者某种程度上相信，只要我们足够努力，完美是有可能的。而自我关怀则是：嘿，现实其实意味着犯错。嗯，没关系。
Let's just see what we can learn from them and grow. So it took a while. But what I started to see in my research that actually people who are more self-compassionate take more responsibility for their mistakes, they're more conscientious and more likely to apologize. Ironically, even though the word self is in self-compassion, when you take that approach, it actually means you don't have to be so self-focused. Christian had discovered something important. One reason many people avoid self-compassion
让我们看看能从中学到什么并从中成长。所以这花了一些时间。但我开始在研究中发现，实际上那些对自己更有同理心的人，会为自己的错误承担更多责任，他们更有责任心，也更有可能道歉。具有讽刺意味的是，尽管自我关怀一词中带有“自我”二字，但当你采取这种方法时，实际上意味着你不必那么过度关注自我。克里斯汀发现了一些重要的事情。许多人逃避自我关怀的一个原因
is because they think being harsh with themselves is the only way to improve. Of course, many of us do not believe this is the case when it comes to dealing with co-workers, or friends, or children. But we turn to old ideas about corporal punishment when it comes to ourselves. The belief that we need to be hard on ourselves, criticize ourselves, to succeed or reach our goals or make a change is actually the number one block to self-compassion we found in the research. People are afraid that they're kind to themselves. They just won't get anything done. So first of all, self-criticism, it kind of works as a motivator. A lot of people get through med school or law school to self-criticism.
是因为他们认为对自己严厉是进步的唯一途径。当然，我们中的许多人在面对同事、朋友或孩子时，并不认为情况如此。但当面对自己时，我们又回到了体罚的旧观念上。我们需要对自己严厉、批判自己，才能成功、达到目标或做出改变，这种信念实际上我们在研究中发现这是自我关怀的第一大阻碍。人们害怕如果对自我仁慈，他们就什么也做不成。所以首先，自我批判在某种程度上起到了激励的作用。很多人通过自我批判熬过了医学院或法学院。
But it works kind of the way corporal punishment works with children. It gets short-term compliance, but it causes a lot of long-term harm. So it may, you may scare yourself or shame yourself into studying more or working harder or whatever it is you need to do to achieve your goals, but it has a lot of long-term negative consequences. So, for instance, it creates anxiety, a little anxiety is okay, but when you have a lot of anxiety, it actually undermines your ability to perform at your best. If you have a lot of shame, shame actually shuts down our ability to learn and to grow because
但它的运作方式有点像体罚对待孩子的方式。它能获得短期的顺从，但会造成大量的长期伤害。所以它可能会、你可能会吓唬自己或让自己感到羞耻，从而去学更多、工作更努力，或者做任何你需要做的事情来达到目标，但这会带来很多长期的负面后果。比如，它会产生焦虑，一点焦虑是没问题的，但当你有大量焦虑时，它实际上会削弱你发挥最佳水平的能力。如果你有大量羞耻感，羞耻感实际上会关闭我们学习和成长的能力，因为
when we've come absorbed and shame, we can't say, well, what did I learn from this mistake? You're just thinking about what a horrible person you are. It leads to things like depression. And again, depression, one of the manifestations of depression is a lack of motivation. So again, it may work in the short term, but in the long one, it's counterproductive. Kristen cites one study that examines the efficacy of self-compassion in learning. Students at our alma mater, UC Berkeley, were given a very difficult vocabulary test. It was designed to be so difficult that all the students failed. They had three groups. One group, they gave a self-esteem boost to,
当我们被羞耻感吞噬时，我们就无法说出：“我从这个错误中学到了什么？”你只会觉得自己是个糟糕透顶的人。它会导致抑郁之类的问题。而且，抑郁症的表现之一就是缺乏动力。所以再次强调，它可能在短期内奏效，但从长远来看，它是适得其反的。克里斯汀引用了一项研究，该研究检验了自我关怀在学习中的效力。她的母校加州大学伯克利分校的学生们被给予了一份非常困难的词汇测试。测试设计得极其艰难，以至于所有学生都考砸了。他们分了三组。第一组，他们给予了自尊提升，
which is, don't worry about it, you must be smart. You got into Berkeley for good and sake, right? Another group, they didn't tell anything, which meant they were probably, these are Berkeley students, so they were probably beating themselves up for failing the vocab test. And the third group, they told to be self-compassionate. You know, hey, it's okay, everyone fails, it was a hard test, try to be kind and supportive to yourself. And then they said, okay, we're going to give you the vocab test again.
也就是，别担心，你肯定很聪明。好歹你也考上了伯克利，对吧？另一组，他们什么也没说，这意味着他们可能——这些都是伯克利学生，所以他们可能因为词汇测试不及格而在内心狠狠地责备自己。第三组，他们被告知要对自己有同理心。你知道，嘿，没关系，每个人都会犯错，这是一场艰难的测试，试着对自己好一点、支持自己。然后他们说：“好了，我们要重新给你进行词汇测试。”
You can study as long as you want, you're some materials, you can study, and just let us know when you're ready to take the next test. And what they found is those people who are told to be self-compassionate about the failure actually study longer for the next test. And study time was associated with how well they did. So it's kind of shows that you may boost your self-esteem, but it's not necessarily going to lead to trying to do any better. Because, hey, I'm already smart. I don't need to study. Or when you're criticizing yourself, it kind of, you know, my undermined durability to study because you're so full of the
你可以复习多久都行，这里有一些材料，你可以复习，准备好参加下一次测试时告诉我们一声。他们发现的是，那些被告知要以自我关怀态度对待失败的人，实际上为下一次测试复习的时间更长。而且复习时间与他们的表现好坏息息相关。所以这有点表明，你可能会提升自尊，但这并不一定会促使你做得更好。因为，嘿，我已经很聪明了。我不需要复习。或者当你批判自己时，它有点，你知道的，削弱了我复习的持久力，因为你充满了
shame or the self-criticism, but saying, hey, it's okay, everyone fails. Why don't I just try again? That's what self-compassion gives you. In your research, you found that self-compassion involves three distinct components. What are they, Christian? In addition to kindness,
羞耻感或自我批判，但如果说：“嘿，没关系，每个人都会犯错。为什么我不再试一次呢？”这就是自我关怀给你的东西。在你的研究中，你发现自我关怀包含三个不同的组成部分。克里斯汀，它们是什么？除了仁慈，
which is really what we've been talking about, one is actually mindfulness, which is the ability to become aware of whatever is happening as it's happening and kind of accept that it is happening. When it comes to our own pain, again, one of that pain is because we've made a mistake or we failed or that pain comes from something happens like the pandemic or something difficult in life, we usually don't want to be mindful of it. We'd like to pretend it's not there, we'd like to turn away, we'd like to rail against it
也就是我们一直在谈论的，其中一个是正念，也就是无论发生什么，都能够意识到它正在发生，并接受它正在发生的能力。当面对我们自己的痛苦时，这种痛苦要么是因为我们犯了错或失败了，要么这种痛苦来自于像大流行或生活中艰难的事情这样偶然发生的事件，我们通常不想对它保持正念。我们倾向于假装它不存在，我们想转身离开，我们想对它大加斥责
and fight against it. In order to be kind to ourselves, we have to acknowledge that we're hurting. It's almost like if a friend called you up and said, hey, I really need to talk, Shankar, I've got this big problem, I'm feeling badly, and you're like, I really need to talk, Shankar, I've got this big problem. I'm feeling badly. And you're like, I'm sorry, I'm too busy. I can't talk to you.
并与之抗争。为了对自己好，我们必须承认我们在受苦。这就像如果一个朋友给你打电话说：“嘿，尚卡尔，我真的需要聊聊，我遇到了一个大问题，我感觉很糟糕，”而你会说：“我真的需要聊聊，尚卡尔，我遇到了一个大问题。我感觉很糟糕。”而你会说：“对不起，我很忙。我不能跟你聊。”
You couldn't give it that way. Your friend compassion. You can't give yourself compassion. And so the first step of self compassion is mindfulness, the willingness to acknowledge that we're hurting. Even if that hurt comes from some failure or mistake we made. And then we need that before we can be kind to ourselves. But as we're being kind to ourselves,
你不能那样回应。你的朋友同理心。你无法对自己产生同理心。因此，自我关怀的第一步是正念，即愿意承认我们在受苦。即使这种痛苦来自于我们所犯的某些失败或错误。然后，在我们能够对自己仁慈之前，我们需要这一点。但是，当我们对自己仁慈时，
what makes it compassion is the sense of connectedness to others. I, you know, have struggled in my life, other people have struggles in their life. This is actually what separates self-compassion from self-pity and it makes all the difference. So I'm seeing these three different threads, their self-kindness, their mindfulness and if you will, a recognition of our common humanity. Yes.
使其成为同理心的，是对他人的连结感。我知道，我在生活中挣扎过，其他人也在生活中挣扎过。这实际上是将自我关怀与自怜区分开来的地方，这产生了巨大的差异。所以，我看到了这三个不同的线索，它们是自我仁慈、正念，以及可以说，对我们共同人性的认可。是的。
And when it comes to the mindfulness component of it, as I was struck by something you were saying, when we are mindful of what we have done, that involves not diminishing what we have done, but also it involves not exaggerating what we have done. So one of the things that mindfulness might give us is it might give us a more accurate picture of what actually we have done rather than minimizing or exaggerating it. Exactly. So mindfulness is kind of as a balance stance that has perspective. And part of the reason we have perspective with self-compassion is we're usually compassionate
而当谈到其中的正念成分时，我被你所说的话深深触动了，当我们对我们所做的事情保持正念时，这既不涉及贬低我们所做的事情，也涉及不夸张我们所做的事情。因此，正念可能带给我们的一件事是，它可能会给我们提供一幅更准确的画面，让我们了解我们实际上做了什么，而不是将其最小化或夸大。完全正确。所以正念有点像一种具有透视力的平衡姿态。我们对自我关怀拥有透视力的部分原因在于，我们通常对他人充满同理心，这感觉很自然。
toward others, that's what feels natural. And so when we're giving compassion to ourselves, we're stepping outside of ourselves to see ourselves as if we were a friend and to say, well, you're really hurting, right? And that distance, instead of being absorbed in the shame, gives us the perspective we need to not ignore, minimize, but also not to exaggerate either. And that's why mindfulness is so key to self-compassion. Hmm.
因此，当我们对自己给予同理心时，我们正在走出自我，将自己视为一个朋友来看待，并说，嗯，你真的很痛苦，对吧？这种距离感，而不是沉浸在羞耻感中，赋予了我们所需的视角，让我们既不忽视、不轻视，也不夸大。这就是为什么正念对自我关怀如此关键。嗯。
Now, in some ways, it's easier said than done, you know, to set aside perfectionism to be kind to yourself, especially if you've spent a lifetime being harsh. You have a very interesting idea about something called a self-compassion break. Tell me about times in your life when you've been caught up with things and you've taken a self-compassion break. Yeah, so the self-compassion break is really quite simple. It involves intentionally bringing in mindfulness, awareness of what's happening to you and the fact that you're struggling,
现在，在某些方面，知易行难，你知道，抛开完美主义去善待自己，特别是如果你一生都在对自己严厉的话。关于所谓的“自我关怀暂停”，你有一个非常有趣的观点。跟我讲讲你生命中那些陷入困境并进行自我关怀暂停的时刻吧。是的，所以自我关怀暂停其实非常简单。它涉及刻意引入正念，意识到正在发生在你身上以及你正在挣扎的事实，
bringing in common humanity, reminding yourself that you aren't alone even though it may feel like it. So whenever you notice there's pain, that's like the alarm on your phone to say, hey, it's time for a self-compassion break. And part of the self-compassion break is not only kind words, which we do use, speaking to yourself like you might speak to a good friend, but also touch, right? The very simple act of putting your hand on your heart
引入共同人性，提醒自己，尽管感觉可能并非如此，但你并不孤单。因此，每当你注意到痛苦时，这就好比手机上的闹钟，在说：“嘿，是时候进行一次自我关怀暂停了。”而自我关怀暂停的一部分不仅是善良的话语（我们确实会使用这些话语，像对好朋友说话那样对自己说话），还有触觉，对吧？把手放在心上这个非常简单的动作，
or maybe on your face, it triggers those memories, the feeling of being cared for by others to touch. And it can take like two minutes to do. And it's like pushing the reset button on a computer makes a huge difference. I'm wondering also if demonstrating more consistent self-compassion can help you become more compassionate to what other people. I mean, does it help you in your relationships with your friends, for example? Does it help you help them become more self-compassionate?
或者可能放在脸颊上，它会唤起那些记忆，通过触觉感受到被他人关爱的感觉。这只需要花两分钟就能完成。这就好像按下电脑的重启按钮一样，会带来巨大的改变。我也在想，表现出更持续的自我关怀是否能帮助你对其他人更有同理心？我的意思是，它对你与朋友的关系有帮助吗？它有助于帮助他们变得更有同理心吗？
So, the answer is yes. Well, first of all, I have to say, some people say you have to be self-compassionate before you can have compassion for others. Actually, in my research, I find that's not the case. Actually, most people are very compassionate towards others and not compassionate toward themselves. But when you are self-compassion, what it does is it allows you to sustain compassion for others without burning out. So if we give and we give and we give toward others and beat ourselves up, eventually our couple run dry and we'll get burnt out, we'll get frustrated, maybe we'll snap an anger. So self-compassion allows you to sustain being there for others. And
所以，答案是肯定的。好吧，首先，我必须说，有些人说你必须先对自己有同理心，然后才能对他人有同理心。实际上，在我的研究中，我发现并非如此。事实上，大多数人对别人非常富有同理心，而对自己却缺乏同理心。但是，当你进行自我关怀时，它所做的是，它使你能够维持对他人的同理心而不会精疲力竭。因此，如果我们不断付出、付出、再付出，却对自己百般苛责，最终我们的精力会耗尽，我们会精疲力竭，会感到沮丧，甚至可能会愤怒爆发。因此，自我关怀使你能够持续陪伴他人。而且
then also what we know from the research as well is that when you model self-compassion out loud, other people learn self-compassion partly through a process of modeling. So when you talk to yourself, instead of beating yourself up, you say something like, well, it's okay, I messed up, it's only human, I'll just try again. Then other people get the message that maybe that's a better way to talk to themselves, and they start being more self-compassionate when they're around you. I'm wondering, Chris, if one way to help people be more compassionate to themselves is to ask themselves how they would respond if the person making a mistake was not them, but
正如我们从研究中所知，当你大声展现自我关怀时，其他人也会部分通过建模的过程来学习自我关怀。所以，当你对自己说话时，你没有严厉苛责自己，而是说：“嗯，没关系，我搞砸了，人无完人，我再试一次就行了。”然后其他人就会收到这样的信息：也许这才是对自己说话的更好方式，当他们和你在一起时，他们也会开始对自己更有同理心。克里斯汀，我在想，帮助人们对自己更有同理心的其中一种方法，是问问他们自己，如果犯错的人不是他们自己，而是
a good friend of theirs. That's actually one of the practices, one of the first practices we teach people for being self-compassionate is to imagine that a good friend they cared about was in the exact same situation that they are. Because naturally, we tend to be, especially their close friends, once we care about, we tend to be compassionate to them. The other thing you could do is you could imagine what that close friend would say to you, and it gives you a model for what type of thing you may say to yourself.
他们的好朋友，他们会作何反应。这实际上是实践之一，是我们教导人们进行自我关怀的首要练习之一，那就是想象一个他们关心的好朋友正处于他们完全相同的境地中。因为自然而然地，我们倾向于，尤其是对亲密的朋友、我们关心的人，我们倾向于对他们充满同理心。你能做的另一件事是，你可以想象那个亲密的朋友会对你说什么，这为你提供了一个模版，告诉你可能会对自己说些什么样的话。
You also talk about the importance of making friends with your inner critic. What do you mean by this? Yeah, this is really key. Again, we shouldn't beat ourselves up for beating ourselves up. But if we can say to our inner critic, I see that you're actually trying to help me with your self-criticism, but maybe there's a more effective way to help myself,
你也谈到了与你的内心批判者交朋友的重要性。你这是什么意思？是的，这真的是关键。再说一次，我们不应该因为自己自我批判而对自己进行批判。但如果我们能对我们的内心批判者说：我看到你实际上正试图通过自我批判来帮助我，但也许有更有效的方法来帮助我自己，
which is actually compassion. It allows our inner critic to feel heard. I mean, again, if we shut down our inner criticism, the part of us that sees the danger is going to try to shout that much louder to be heard. But if we say, Hey, I hear you. Got it. Thank you so much for pointing out that this behavior is causing harm. You know, this isn't very helpful. I hear you. Thank you. But I think with a way I'm going to try to approach this is through encouragement to make a change, as opposed to shame to make a change, it's
那就是同理心。它让我们的内心批判者感到被倾听。我的意思是，如果我们关闭了内心批判，那个看到危险的部分就会试图喊得更大声，以便被人听到。但如果我们说：“嘿，我听到了。明白了。非常感谢你指出这种行为正在造成伤害。你知道，这并不是很有帮助。我听到了。谢谢。但我认为我尝试采取的方法是通过鼓励来做出改变，而不是通过羞耻来改变，这
actually going to be more effective. Are there examples, Kristen, in your own recent life where you've helped someone else show greater compassion for themselves? Well, so my son, for instance, so my son, I have to try to help him have compassion all the time. My son, you might think because. So my son, I have to try to help him have compassion all the time. My son, you might think because he's my son, is never self-critical, but his autism actually causes them to be very self-critical because when he beats himself up, he's under the illusion that somehow that's going to allow him to control things so he won't make mistakes. So whether he gets a grade, he doesn't want
实际上会更有效。”克里斯汀，在你最近的生活中，有没有什么例子，是你帮助其他人对他们自己表现出更多的同理心？嗯，比如我的儿子，我的儿子，我不得不时刻试着帮他建立同理心。我的儿子，你可能会认为，因为。嗯，比如我的儿子，我不得不时刻试着帮他建立同理心。我的儿子，你可能会认为因为他是我的儿子，所以从不自我批判，但他的自闭症实际上导致他非常自我批判，因为当他责备自己时，他有一种错觉，认为某种程度上那能让他控制事情，这样他就不会犯错。所以无论是他得了他不想要的成绩
in school or, one time, he forgot his keys when he needed them and he was just beating himself up. For years, who existed me, he's like, don't give me that self-compassion stuff, mommy, because he was going through his adolescent rebellion like all kids do. Now he really gets it. So now for instance, I'll hear him say to himself when he makes a mistake, it's okay, everyone makes mistakes. It's not the end of the world. And it's actually helping them cope now. I want to spend a little time talking about the research that you and others have done into the benefits of self-compassion.
在学校里，或者有一次，他需要钥匙却忘带了，然后他就在那里狠狠地责备自己。多年来，这对我来说一直存在，他会说：“别跟我来那一套自我关怀，妈妈，”因为他像所有孩子一样，正在经历青春期叛逆。现在他真的懂了。所以现在，举个例子，我会听到他在犯错时对自己说：“没关系，人都会犯错。这不是世界末日。”这实际上正在帮助他应对这一切。我想花点时间和大家谈谈你和其他人对自我关怀益处的研究。
I'm imagining that there are some people who are listening to this who say, you know, this is just happy talk, you know, just being kind to yourself. But you and others have found that there's actually empirical backing at an emotional level, at a practical level, for the benefits of self-compassion. Can you describe that work to me, please? Yeah, well, the literature now is huge. It's approaching 4,000 studies on the benefits of self-compassion. So it ain't just happy talk, right? And these studies are either by looking at people who are naturally more self-compassionate. They tend to be happier, more satisfied with their lives, less depressed, less anxious, more motivated.
我想象肯定有一些人在听这个节目时会说：“你知道，这只是心灵鸡汤，你知道，就是对自己好一点。”但你和其他人发现，在情感层面、在实用层面，自我关怀的好处实际上有着实证支持。能给我描述一下这项工作吗？是的，现在文献资料非常庞大。关于自我关怀益处的研究正接近4000项。所以这不仅仅是心灵鸡汤，对吧？这些研究要么是通过观察那些天生更具自我关怀的人。他们往往更快乐、对生活更满意、更少抑郁、更少焦虑、更有动力。
There's also a lot of experimental research, either putting people in a self-compassionate frame of mind in the moment, or else training them to be self-compassionate over the long run. And again, people are less likely to contemplate suicide. They eat better. They sleep better. They're less likely to engage in behaviors like addiction or ways to try to escape their pain that are unhealthy.
还有很多实验研究，要么是将人们置于当下的自我关怀心态中，要么是训练他们在长期内保持自我关怀。同样，人们自杀的念头也更少。他们吃得更好。他们睡得更好。他们不太可能从事诸如成瘾或试图逃避痛苦的不健康行为。
They're more likely to practice safe sex, right? When you care about yourself, you're more likely to do things that protect yourself. The benefits go on and on and makes you stronger. When you're an inner ally to yourself, you're going to be much more capable of getting through the hard times than when you're an enemy and you know cut yourself down. So the research is, well, of course, I'm a little biased, but I think it's incontrovertible at this point that self-compassion is good for well-being. You and a colleague once looked at the role of self-compassion in relationships and the effects it had on personal and intimate relationships.
他们更有可能实行安全性行为，对吧？当你关心自己时，你更有可能做那些保护自己的事情。好处数不胜数，它让你变得更强大。当你成为自己的内心同盟时，你将比作为敌人并自我贬低时更有能力度过艰难时期。所以这项研究，好吧，当然，我有点偏见，但我认为现在无可辩驳的是，自我关怀对幸福感是有益的。你和一位同事曾探讨过自我关怀在关系中的作用及其对个人和亲密关系的影响。
What did you find? Yeah, so it was really interesting. So we had couples and we had each person in the couple fill out the self-compassion scale, but we had people write their partner's behaviors. How intimate is your partner with you? How kind are they to you? How supportive are they to you? How often do they get angry at you or get in negative behaviors?
你们发现了什么？是的，这真的很有趣。所以我们有许多对情侣，我们让情侣中的每个人都填写了自我关怀量表，但我们让人们写下他们伴侣的行为。你的伴侣对你有多亲密？他们对你有多好？他们对你有多支持？他们多久对你生气一次或者陷入消极行为中？
And what we found is that people who are more self-compassionate were rated by their partners as being much better relationship partners, as being closer, more caring, more intimate, they felt more satisfied with self-compassion at partners, and basically that's because when we resource ourselves with self-compassion and warm-think care that actually gives us more resources to give to others. When we are lost in shame and self-criticism, we actually have less emotional energy to give to others. It's almost a paradox isn't it, that the more we're able to see our imperfections, the
我们发现的是，那些更具自我关怀的人被伴侣评为更好的关系伴侣，更亲密、更有爱心、更亲密，他们对自我关怀的伴侣感到更满意，基本上这是因为当我们用自我关怀和温暖的关怀来滋养自己时，这实际上给了我们更多的资源去给予他人。当我们迷失在羞耻和自我批判中时，我们实际上没有那么多的情感能量去给予他人。这几乎是一个悖论，不是吗？我们越能看到自己的不完美，
more we can do something about it, the more we beat up on ourselves for our imperfections the less we can do about it. Exactly, so Carl Rogers famously said, the curious paradox is the more I accept to myself, the more I can change. But it's not like I have to change in order to be worthy. It's I want to change because I care about myself and I don't want to suffer. It's a much more effective type of motivation and more sustainable in the long run. Kristen Neff is a psychologist at the University of Texas at Austin. She is the author of
我们就越能为此做些什么；我们越是因为自己的不完美而痛殴自己，我们就越无能为力。完全正确，所以卡尔·罗杰斯有一句名言：奇怪的悖论是，当我越是接纳自己，我就越能改变。但这并不是说为了变得有价值我就必须改变。而是因为我关心自己，我不想受苦，所以我想改变。这是一种更有效的动机，从长远来看也更具可持续性。克里斯汀·内夫是德克萨斯大学奥斯汀分校的心理学家。她是
self-compassion, the proven power of being kind to yourself, and fear self-compassion, how women can harness kindness to speak up, claim their power, and thrive. Christian, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you Shankar, it's been a pleasure. If you have follow-up questions for Christian Neff and are willing to share them with a hidden brain audience, please record a short voice memo and send it to us at ideasathydenbrain.org. That email address again is ideasathydenbrain.org. 60 seconds is plenty. Please use the subject line, self-compassion. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes
《自我关怀：善待自己的经证实力》（Self-Compassion: The Proven Power of Being Kind to Yourself）以及《无畏的自我关怀：女性如何利用善良发声、夺回力量并蓬勃发展》一书的作者。克里斯汀，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔，这真是个愉快的过程。如果你对克里斯汀·内夫有后续问题，并愿意与《隐藏的大脑》听众分享，请录制一段简短的语音备忘录发送给我们，邮箱是：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。再次重复邮箱地址是：ideas@hiddenbrain.org。60秒就足够了。请使用主题行：自我关怀。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏大脑传媒制作。我们的音频制作团队包括
Bridget McCarthy, Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you liked today's episode, please share it with three people who could use a reminder to show themselves a bit of self-compassion. If they are new to podcasting, please help them to subscribe to our show.
布里奇特·麦卡锡、安妮·墨菲·保尔、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·夸雷勒、瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯和安德鲁·查德威克。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。如果你喜欢今天的节目，请把它分享给三位需要提醒自己展现一点自我关怀的人。如果他们是播客新手，请帮助他们订阅我们的节目。
I'm Shankar Vidantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。我们回头见。这集节目还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。